bonjour assez gentil hein j'adore
j'adore je vais les mettre là comment ça
va sallabi r1 très bien sales gosses de
celle où la wii c'est oui je viens
souvent j'habite juste là c'est bien
pour faire une hyper mais c'est bien on
buvait quoi du 20 mai au petit mozart
je peux avoir une coupe de champagne
s'il vous plaît à la vente
à la vôtre
tiens alors cette promo ça vous fait
quoi toutes les télévisions
ouais
presse écrite télévision
j'ai fait quoi comme télévision non
j'ai fait un journal télévisé
[Musique]
on pensera jeu pertes
voilà marc paris 1er
[Musique]
c
c'est pas fatiguant ça qu'on vous pose
toujours les mêmes questions
ces termes il a tracé de paris dernière
nous mâcher la dernière mais voilà c'est
pour ça que je voulais faire le bilan
pour faire le bilan de la formation
oui et tout le monde nous a posé les
mêmes questions est ce que là c'est un
peu rude parce que des fois j'ai
l'impression de déclencher un petit un
petit disque alors quand on pose une
question différente est formidable
finalement quelque chose que l'on m'a
demandé est ce que c'est
est ce que vous arrivez à répéter
toujours la même chose en donnant
l'impression que c'est inventé mais si
actrice je vous regarde vous êtes facile
on était extrêmement belle
je vous ai adoré je trouve un homme a
maintenant sérieusement je crois pas en
compliments à vendre ça va parce que je
suis très méfiante
et je vois comme je suis ouais il est
courant vous n'avez pas vous n'êtes pas
de nom j'aimais votre âge dans paris
match c'est étonnant donc lille on a
vieilli avant ils ont envie de combien
non non non mais c'est quand même mettre
de vieillir nous
ouais quand je veux vieilli au cinéma
vous la chance que vous avez quand même
c'est que
vous êtes soit sur un tas de pellicule
m
votre image moins
bah oui
c'est sage et guépards vous pensez bien
qu on le regardera encore dans 100 ans
ah oui extraordinaire oui c'est
formidable et et demi on le regardera
aussi en plus on est la fille j'ai
arrêté pour l'éternité c'est à dire dans
un moment un instant magique avec des
gens formidables et quand je vois que
ces films je me souviens tout ce qui est
que derrière la caméra tout ce qui se
passait les rencontres se comptent y est
déjà
mais quand tu fellini delon belmondo le
solaire mastroianni les marques
john wayne et
et beaucoup d'autres donc c'est
fondane sean connery c'est magique non
pour une petite gamine oui ce nom ah oui
d'ailleurs au début j'étais plutôt
paniqué je dormais avec mon scénario
sous l'oreiller ce que j'avais pas mais
moi je crois il ya une chose qui
extraordinaire dans vos clips c'est
d'abord effectivement toutes les
rencontres que la pluie vous raconter
les sommes que vous refusez ceux qui
finissent par arriver à leurs fins prêts
pour que vous
d'après ce que j'en sais seulement
belmondo aps condensé titre petites
choses et beaucoup beaucoup vous en
draguer et vous avez été très très
stoïque en boutons de braguette way
warren beatty par exemple s'est rien
passé il a fait croire que
mais warren c'était mignon bien
tu es mon chevet des serments pendant
quelque temps parce que tout le monde a
voulu voir dans vos clics c'est cette
histoire évidemment de votre enfance
quoiqu'il absolument il semble bien que
sa belle voix que ça parce que je vais
dire pourquoi une expression dans votre
équilibre
vous dites vous parlez de la fatalité du
mal c'est à dire que les femmes à un
moment
[Musique]
on se sens la fatalité du mas blanc oui
les femmes sont habitués à d'abord je
dis aussi que les femmes sont beaucoup
plus forte et qu'elle arrive à surmonter
tous les problèmes des gens qui ont
beaucoup plus délicat les femmes
elle doit s'occuper de la maison d'abord
de la famille des enfants des devoirs
qui l ont leur travail les pièces dans
leurs problèmes
pas le droit de ramallah n'excède puis
en plus on a aussi cette violence du
s'est pas encore fini est-ce que vous
avez vu la petite sarah
qui se passe à l'otan voici ne changera
de dubaï oui oui finalement c'est un peu
comme votre histoire quoi ce que vous
il était un peu moins
- vieux un peu moins les apparemment
quand même maintenant je pense à la
fatalité du mal parce que votre histoire
en fait quand je lisais le bouquin je le
disais que c'était un film italien et
vous devriez vous qui connaissez
beaucoup de monde dans le cinéma
je suis sûr que vous devriez faire un
film de ça avec l'histoire d'une petite
sicilienne qui vit à tunis qu'on appelle
claude et qui certains refus de féminité
alors quand on vous a vu après si ça
laisse pantois les pivots l'histoire de
ce type qui vous prendre force et
finalement il ya un sentiment attraction
répulsion comme vous comme brûler et
puis vous partez à rome vous tournez vos
premiers films enceinte et moi je trouve
que il ya un film magnifique à faire
avec gm annoncée
non pas vraiment ah bon je suis sûr que
n'importe quel producteur digne de ce
nom devrait racheter les droits du livre
pour faire un film sur cette histoire
parce que ça commence bon tunis machin
il ya ce type qui la poursuit qui
l'attend à l'école enfin tout ça qui est
toujours présent qui après elle s'enfuit
mais quand elle s'enfuit enfin quand
vous vous appuyez vous enfuyez pas
n'importe où dans filles et à rome et
puis c'est pas pour faire n'importe quoi
pour faire des films qui sont mais c'est
quand même très connu c
extraordinaire ce qui s'est passé
c'était un accident bah oui mais c'est
ce qui aurait pu être moi je sculpte
d'expérience dans des stades
bah oui c'est ça c'est que ce que parce
que la pièce un drame en fait pour une
fille je dirais commune
vous ça vous a c'est ce qui vous a fait
devenir star finalement sourire parce
que ça m'a donné le pen sa machine bah
oui ça m'a j'étais déterminé j'étais
couvrir c'est l'énergie du désespoir mon
à la ba oui c'est ça bien plus gt gt sûr
à être bonnes java j'étais sûr je me
disais toujours d'ailleurs ou des mieux
quand je quand je jouais dans ses films
les premiers films je parlais très très
bas j'avais peur que mentale parce que
je me disais ils vont s'apercevoir que
je sais rien fait ils vont s'apercevoir
est très bas moi je trouve là vous avez
été extrêmement courageuse et
extrêmement courageux souvent mais là
vous avez des très courageuse c'est de
garder cet enfant parce que
je trouve que ça c'est le côté s'ils
signent un accord ils veulent pas quoi
ah non j'ai pas pu ne pas le garder
c'est c'est ma vie c'est lui qui a
déclenché toute ma vie il c'est lui qui
a décidé de ma vie
donc si je suis là c'est pour lui que
vous avez peur ce soir j'ai un dîner mon
mari est arrivé de rome la gelée vue à
tout à l'heure avant très en retard et
pas kevin circulation terrible ouais on
est un dîner puis demain on va partir
maisons en vendée oui dans quel coin
aubade en pays d'auge
alors c'est moi j'ai une maison dans
l'orne à vous c'est bien là bas ça vous
plaît j'aime beaucoup la chancellerie un
feu de cheminée lajarrige ardeurs aussi
marcher donc j'adore la nature j'adore
ça me ressource
j'aime beaucoup regarder vos films des
fois oui
ouais c'est à dire ça
[Musique]
alors
je m'appelle s'est passé j'ai fait
beaucoup de marée bah oui bien sûr je
préfèrerais mai
pas beaucoup parce que j'ai
j'ai quand même eu un privilège
extraordinaire j'ai tourné avec des gens
formidables
je n'ai jamais montré diminue non j'ai
trop de respect pour la femme je trouve
que quand on dévoile tout y'a plus rien
à découvrir
je trouve que le mystère c'est c'est
plus fascinantes
donc à aucun serait que la part aux âmes
jamais personne vous avez complètement
nue
et on me l'a très souvent quand on
commence un fils et une scène un peu
comme ça ils ont toujours l'impression
qu'à la dernière minute la crise va dire
oui un m'est arrivé notamment dans les
professionnels avec lancaster richard
brooks ont été un monument valley donc
c'était bon c'est extraordinaire il y
avait une scène où je devais
pratiquement enlevé mon chemisier
richard boufflers des sûr que j'allais
faire ces derniers non j'ai dit non j'ai
dit nous gênions coup non c'est ça les
siciliens et sans douleur et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de l'inaptitude
abonnez vous mettez un pouce bleus